[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you win in your financial life
your professional life and in your
relational life i'm ken coleman george
campbell joining me this hour as we take
your calls america you might just be one
phone call away from that nudge you've
needed to go the direction you believe
you're supposed to go maybe you're going
to get breakthrough
but i can tell you this uh george and i
have a blast serving you
uh in the capacity of just that sounding
board that advisor that coach and so
george will help you with your money
questions i'm on deck today to help you
uh if you want to get a bigger shovel in
the form of maybe pivoting into a
different field or maybe just a
promotion where you are to get out of
debt faster start that side hustle
george and i are combined today to talk
about those issues so you ready to go
yes ken you look tan and happy this
afternoon well i appreciate that i i
just walked off the golf course wow you
know thank goodness for the showers at
the old club and zip right in here to
help america so it's been a good friday
already absolutely so let's go jason
starts us off in our nation's capital
washington d.c jason how can we help
um yes i'm currently on baby steps four
five and six and i want to pay off my
house as quickly as possible but at the
same time i realize i need to put away
money for things like
five years i need a roof hvac
replacement car things like that
i'm just not quite sure how to go about
it properly okay so you've got some
extra money that you want to throw
towards the house but you also have some
big upcoming expenses
years from now so you're going how do i
plan for this it's a great question are
you doing a monthly budget currently
yes i am okay so in your monthly budget
what i want you to do is have line items
for sinking funds and so this all that
means is every single month you're going
to put away 50 bucks into this fund at
the end of the year you've got 600 bucks
after three years it's 1800 and so you
build that based on what you think the
repair will be and when you will need to
do it okay so do you have any idea i
know it's hard to guess when you know
you're gonna need to replace a roof but
you said you've got about a five year
time horizon
um yeah my it's
my house was built with like
the the cheaper type of products and the
house is 17 years old so let's say it
has
five to seven years left okay so if you
guess the roof's going to be 10 grand
we're gonna divide that by five that's
two grand a year and now we know exactly
how much to put in our monthly budget to
hit that goal
okay but i love your thinking because
what most people do is they go well it's
an emergency but truthfully an emergency
needs to be urgent necessary and
unexpected
and you know this roof is in poor
condition so we know we're gonna have to
replace it so i would be about the
business of paying off that house early
and have those sinking fund line items
in your every dollar budget so that
you're ready when the time comes yeah
great advice
jason appreciate the call thank you very
much george you're mr insurance guy you
got an instagram i don't know that's a
good personal brand but i appreciate
that well you have an instagram reel
that's quite popular about all the types
of crazy insurance but are you aware and
i'm bringing this up it's relevant to
jason i know you're going where are you
going with this uh
but uh you if you have hail damage
that has happened to your roof
uh within a certain amount of time
you have you could uh your insurance
could end up paying for the uh roof oh
yeah even if you have other issues are
you aware of this yeah you gotta find a
good roofer and you gotta know your
policy exactly and a good roofer who
knows what they're doing can be your
advocate uh to uh help you get most of
that paid for so it's just something to
think about yeah and you need to have
good proof and so it's it's nice to do
it as soon as it happens as soon as it
happens get a roofer over there there's
like a statute of limitations there's
about a length of but look at your
policy but something to look into i feel
a little scared
stepping into your area no not at all
it's a great call out and a lot of
people aren't aware of what does my
insurance cover i haven't looked at my
policy and truth be told looking through
one of those insurance policies i mean
it is dreadful i'd rather rather watch
paint dry yeah but we just did a
campaign called confidence in your
coverage it's completely free and you
can get it at ramseysolutions.com
confidence and i walk you through over
five days five real short fun videos
everything you need to know about
insurance and make sure you get a
checkup because a lot of people are
number one underinsured number two
overpaying oh yeah what's a great way to
get a raise
ramseysolutions.com
confidence there it is ramsay
solutions.com conference it really is
fun george and the team did a great job
with that and it's actually really
helpful i try really hard as you know
you do well james is up next in chicago
illinois james how can we help
thank you so much for having me on
i just wanted to ask i'm a junior in
high school and i'm going in my junior
year and i've saved up a bit of money
from various jobs i've worked and gifts
i've received and i want to be a good
steward of it and want to invest some of
it
and if you were me and had a thousand
dollars to invest somewhere where where
would you suggest doing it
james first of all i want to say that
you are like a 60 year old man trapped
inside a 15 year old body how are you so
mature so young you have some great
parents thank you
yeah my parents have really helped me
out with investing advice and learning
how to manage my money and
i really have them to thank for it and
also my grandpa that is awesome well to
your question you got a thousand bucks
where you where should you invest it
number one i want you to invest it in
james because you're 15 you've got a lot
of life ahead of you your education
goals you're gonna need to save up and
buy a car there's a lot of life expenses
to where i don't want you to be have no
liquid cash because it's all tied up in
investments
but to answer your question truthfully
you could open a roth ira custodial roth
ira and if you have earned income and
you can put that money in there and
invest that in good gross stock mutual
funds inside of that
perfect thank you so much all right
absolutely 15 years old that's amazing
yeah and very mature very professional
yeah and a junior
yeah that was another question i had
that's i guess that's fairly normal 15
16 oh 17 years no george yeah
you've
usually
16
kid who's about i have a 16 year old
junior so he's a little bit ahead of the
game it feels like in every area of his
life well clearly james is this guy is
going to graduate next year that's who i
was talking about yeah
your son
who knows
that's a whole other story oh that's
fantastic
hey every time you hear someone do their
debt free scream on this show it's
because they at some point said enough
i'm not going to live like this anymore
i've had it and when you get mad like
that do what they did your life will
change too right now inflation and your
stupid credit cards are killing you
you started to believe you are not in
control of your money wrong
you are in control but you have to
decide to control what you can control
and that's you your behavior you've got
the power to change your future and
financial peace university will show you
how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10 million people beat debt
master budgeting budgeting rather and
build wealth and you could do it too
stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say enough
and decide to take back control start
financial peace university at
ramseysolutions.com
enough
ramsay
solutions.com slash enough i like that
i like the enough yeah you know what i
mean it's got a lot of emotion to it
which is how people are feeling yeah and
i think that's true hey i will say this
uh just some positive news
july jobs report came out and we added
500 000 plus jobs so the sky is not
falling i can tell say
that despite all the negative news and
everybody trying to scare you to death
this is a baby recession
i don't think this is a big bad
you know bully recession so everybody
relax economy's still adding jobs
despite high inflation so it's gonna be
okay hang in there all right speaking of
it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
fantastic because coming up more of your
calls america he's george campbell i'm
ken coleman and this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
helping you win in life in your money
and your work
in your relationships this is the ramsey
show i'm ken coleman george campbell my
colleague and fellow ramsey personality
joins me as we team up to help you on
this fine day so if you are feeling
stuck
you got a toxic boss or toxic team or
you feel like you're in a dead-end job
and you're i'm in the baby steps can i
move
dancers yes
and i can help with that today and then
of course george is here
helping answer your money calls so let's
get to it edwin joins us in the big
apple george new york city
new york edwin how can we help
hey what's up guys thanks for taking my
call you can hear me okay yes sir
cool cool so my question is i think i'm
ready to move out i'm 22.
um should i build an emergency fund
before moving to another state i want to
move to another state as a whole
do you have a job lined up there
no i don't do you know where you're
going to live
yeah i want to go to south carolina
somewhere in south carolina or florida
no snow no cold okay and you're going to
rent an apartment somewhere over there
yeah i'm looking at about like 800 a
month is what i could afford
okay what's your take-home pay
on the minimum 40 000 from my full-time
job if i do my part-time or get any
part-time i think i could do about 50
000. okay so before george gets through
the money stuff are you planning to save
up enough to then get on the ground in
south carolina and then look for a job
is that the idea
well that's my question as a you know
i've never got out my parents house
should i just because i've listened to a
few ramsey videos before about moving
out should i just get out there
and get my rent and worry about the
emergency fund later or should i lock
down i don't want you to worry at all
about anything that would be my plan and
that means having a job lined up and
having money in the bank i'd have a
place to go
uh and i'm talking about a professional
place to go in south carolina i'd get a
job
and gotcha and there's no need any and
here i mean look could you and george
can weigh in here and he's gonna tell
you how and he's the genius on this
stuff thank you uh but
uh could you save up enough money and
get to south carolina and you know then
find yeah but it's just not necessary
it's gonna add stress too yeah there's
no need for an interruption in income
this is one of the strongest job
economies we've ever seen
again i just mentioned this everyone if
you didn't hear me
the july jobs report we created another
500 000 jobs so we still have uh
somewhere between the latest numbers
10.6 and 11.3 million jobs out there so
it's still a wonderful market
and and here's the deal um
you know you can find something down
there take several trips
i'd be saving up money to make some
trips down there make some connections
decide where i'm gonna work then where
i'm going to live
uh and then not have any interruption in
income george yeah edwin what's driving
the urgency it feels like you're kind of
done living with the parents and it
feels like there's something behind that
yeah i've so for 22 years i've mainly
lived with my mom and grandma and like
my grandfather he's not really in the
picture so you know i've lived with two
ladies mainly my whole life
um the men my grandma's getting a little
old now and my mom is kind of putting
pressure on me like i got to be
successful and take care of her
for my mom
and then my mom also puts pressure like
well i got to take care of her when i'm
mostly successful so it's just a lot you
know i feel like i'm striving compared
to my parents so so are you saying if
you moved to south carolina you would be
you'd have obligation to take care of
grandma
i'd have less obligation because my mom
also lives in my in the house with us so
like
she's an adult but at the same time
i'd want you running to something
instead of away from something and so
that's what i'm trying to dig at here
uh to make sure that we're going for the
right reason and not just because man i
don't want this pressure from mom
anymore i'm getting out
i want you to move out and be on your
own you got what do you do for work
making 40 50 grand a year
i'm a cnc machinist right now okay have
you looked to see if there's jobs like
that in south carolina
oh there's plenty oh yeah okay so let's
talk about the mom issue is she
financially stable or does she have no
retirement what's her financial outlook
nah she's not stable um
she lived with my grandma for basically
all adult life
i think i make more than her right now
she works for honeywell which is pretty
good but i make more than her and she
just told me like why should i give more
money to the man
and why should i put in more than 40
hours a week and i'm like if you want
something in life a certain thing you're
gonna have to you know
uh what is the sacrifice and put in some
more hours and you know take more taxes
off i don't know but i'm guessing
considering she's the one who powdered
your butt she doesn't want to hear it
from you
absolutely absolutely i talked about
roll-off iras and you know paying off
your student debt mom you're 45 and she
doesn't want anything out of it so well
i got to tell you as well i think edwin
you moving out is a good move i don't
think you need to feel this bird no
matter what mom says to take care of her
i think in some ways
you getting out on your own
and
uh becoming a uh you know baby steps
millionaire
uh showing her what you've done she's
still really young
uh you know she can turn things around
but instead of you telling her i think
you've got to model this for her and i i
do think the move is good uh but but our
advice is go find something in south
carolina and so there's no interruption
in income
and uh you're off and running yeah if
you got no debt and a fully funded
emergency fund and a job lined up this
is gonna be a fun move and you're gonna
look forward to something instead of get
there and be stressing out yeah thanks
for the call edwin salvador joins us
next in fort wayne indiana salvador how
can we help
hey ken and george thank you guys for
taking my car i really appreciate it you
bet what's happening today
so me and my wife have been doing the
baby steps we've been about two months
in uh we've already paid 4 500 in credit
card debt so we're officially free from
that great um
and we have a little bit of a fun
argument here uh we got two
pieces of debt left besides our house we
got the card debt and the student loan
payment debt how much is the car four
thousand what is it the car the car is
twelve thousand six hundred okay
and the student loan is four thousand
and
my my question is we have enough money
to pay off the student loan
like
today if we wanted to
uh we could pay that off just go online
make a payment and we're done
and that's what she's wanting to do but
i'm wanting to put as much money towards
that twelve thousand
dollar payment uh because we you know
that student loans are on pause right
now
um i don't believe we're going to get a
student loan forgiveness but you're not
just knowing that i don't have to pay
that for a month right now i'm wondering
which one we should go to next so
uh that's what i'm calling
well it's a great question and uh i
think your wife is right on this one and
if you're following our plan and our
plan if we don't take into account
what's happening with the white house
and what are they gonna do or not gonna
do and is it pause and is it zero
percent interest all we look at is the
smallest balance what is the next
smallest debt we can knock out today to
feel the progress to stay motivated to
become completely debt-free and so when
you look at it with that kind of tunnel
vision you go all right the student
loan's gone today and we're off to the
races with the credit card how much do
you guys have in savings
uh so we have we do have the emergency
fund thousand dollar emergency fund and
we have a little over three thousand um
into that
uh
in our savings so a little over four
thousand um if we wanted to pay the
student loan off i'm actually selling a
lot of stuff on ebay to make money
so it it's doable um to pay that student
loan off immediately well don't don't do
that if it's gonna be mean dipping into
that starter emergency fund because this
is not an emergency now once you have
that ebay money in your bank account
then we can pay that student loan off in
full is that one loan that's four
thousand
yes and that's all me
so we're talking maybe a week or two
from now you've got actual four thousand
sitting in your account outside of the
starter emergency fund clean up that
student loan debt and we can get rid of
that car debt soon after that what's
your household income
yeah uh my wife's stay-at-home mom we
have a two-year-old and i'm making uh
50. so at start we were only making 40
and i
got a kick in the butt from dave ramsey
and all that so i got a promotion and
now we're making 50. there we go
well you'll clean up that uh car loan in
no time man keep selling stuff on ebay
get side hustles let's get rid of this
thing in the next year and be completely
debt-free and on our way to building
wealth did you hear that george salvador
got himself a promotion
he took control ken he got himself a
promotion
bigger paycheck
bigger shovel bigger shovel hey who can
i help today get a better job with a
better paycheck come on let's go all
right give us a call triple 825-5225
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues
to take your phone calls to give you
hope filled
practical steps to win in your money
your work and your relationships i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me this
hour as we take your calls phoenix
arizona is where we go next joe joins us
there
joe how can we help
hi uh thanks for the call how are you
doing well we're doing fantastic how can
we help
uh so let me give you a very quick
financial snapshot uh i make 85 000 a
year uh my wife needs about 10 grand but
but she just started her new business
but so that's only going up from there
i'm working at company a uh i i'm i like
my job uh
but i also hate debt at the same time
and we're looking to buy a house at the
moment
so i have this potential opportunity at
company b and i'm i really seem to like
that uh this new job as well
um and it puts us in a place and a
market where it's actually possible for
us to
eventually buy a house completely debt
free
so my question is should i
take the plunge go for this new job or
uh should i just stick around in this in
company a sure are they in the same
industry are they completely different
industries
same industry same industry
and how similar is the work at this new
opportunity at company b is it totally
different or is it similar to what you
do now
it's similar but it's it it also aligns
more with what i actually want to do
ding ding ding that was my next question
and you answered it for me joe so that's
a really good sign how much more money
will you be making initially
about uh fifteen percent more fifty
percent more second yeah and uh how
confident are you
that uh you will grow beyond the 15
in the next let's call it year two three
years
pretty confident because uh company b is
uh a lot smaller than company a but they
are really good in what they do or in
their business area have they offered
you the job to grow them
um
almost so they want to invite me to the
location for a tour and stuff at this
point and then they want to make me an
offer right well that's right if they
make you an offer
uh
and you have found out beyond everything
you just told me that it's obviously a
really good culture you want to do your
homework talk to people who work there
do some homework online what do their
customers say about them
you know you want to do your homework
just to get an idea what kind of people
are they how do they treat their people
and if it looks like a healthy
organization it feels like a no-brainer
and yet you called to say what should i
do do you have any concerns that we
haven't heard
well uh so the thing is i've only been
at company a for about a year now and i
just feel conflicted within myself like
i'm you know i'm probably gonna you know
make my managers and my bosses mad
i've heard this call many times before
george i don't want to upset anyone i
get it i'm a people pleaser ken
we all do i don't want anyone mad at me
that's what it is so it comes across in
the form of guilt right joe
yeah that's correct yeah but here's the
deal you're not doing anything unethical
if you were to leave company a true or
false
yeah it's not unethical it's not illegal
or anything like that oh yeah he
answered my next question i like joe he
gets ahead of me and uh one step ahead i
like this joe yeah joe there's nothing
for you to have any guilt about do you
understand so joe so george nailed this
it always presents as guilt
but what it really is is a fear
of what someone's going to think about
you and a fear of what someone's going
to say about you when you leave and
that's normal so the truth is you can
leave in a lot of ways and a lot of
people do it poorly and there's a chunk
of people who do it really well and
respectfully and they leave on good
terms quote unquote well and and that's
a very good point george but joe even if
you leave well
there's some people that just will be
uh
nasty
and there's nothing you can do to
control that i take it as a compliment
because that means they miss me oh he's
gonna miss me yeah oh i like that yeah i
i think joe this is
they've all been really good to me so
that's that's me feel all the more
conflicted yeah but but here's the deal
are you going to regret if you pass this
up
um
i could maybe the one of the things is
that the wife and i are definitely
wanting to move out of phoenix ever
since we got here so does company b
allow you to do better so does company b
allow you to move out of phoenix
that's correct joe you're making a heck
of a case it checks off all the bucks i
don't know why listen you should not be
conflicted anymore
you will resent listen you will resent
this company and you will resent
yourself if you don't do this
okay okay i understood all right man
pull hey listen rip the band-aid off
only after
they offer you the job you gotta sign
contract then then resign and leave well
and keep your head up keep looking
forward appreciate the call joe jesse's
up in columbia missouri jesse how can we
help
hey ken hey george hey how you doing
doing great man i'm just nervous awesome
well i don't think you're at least i
talked to austin i just i can't even
believe well now austin's a big she's
world famous he's he's a cool dude you
ought to see the hat this guy's wearing
today but george and i
no need to be nervous talking to us i
mean we're just a couple of chuckleheads
so i'm five six on a good day i'm not
interested that's in his platform shoes
what's up okay so uh so i am i'm 21
years old um i make uh
may i make over 100k right now i've been
been very
been very diligent my you know since out
of high school i went i was going to go
to school but it just wasn't my route
it worked out for you and a boy
what are you doing now all glory to god
all glory um i do a foundation repair
i'm a foreman for a company here in
columbia
wow okay
all right what's your question
okay so my real question is uh
right now um i've got i've got my
emergency fund i'm out of debt i mean my
life's in good shape right now
completely but uh
really i would say the next step would
be of course buying a house eventually i
ran at the moment with my girlfriend but
uh
anyhow
from there
uh i'm just nervous you're doing great
you're doing great
what's your what's your question on what
to do really really it's more so just i
don't want i have so much money saving
up right now i'm kind of just wondering
if there's a better way instead of just
having it all sitting in my check-in
savings account if there was maybe if i
should start investing i mean i have a
roth in everything there but more or
less if i should start investing some of
that money if i could if it would grow
better there and then pull it out later
when i'm ready to yeah what's our time
horizon how long uh how far away is this
house purchase
maybe maybe five years you know
why five years you make 100k with no
debt
uh
i'm i mean just kind of in a comfortable
place right now
truthfully i mean just you just told me
your stated goal was i want to buy a
house
what that's not my main main goal i
guess i mean
really i think my main goal is just to
become a millionaire but
you know you'll get there naturally and
a home purchase can be a part of that
i'm just wondering why five years and
not two or three years
well yeah three to five how much money
do you have right now
so i've got about 35 in the bank and
that's outside of your emergency fund
not connected no that no that's included
in my emergency so how much money can
you save up per year adding to that
account
30
40k 50k
uh yes
okay so now let's set a goal to say hey
the house that i'm looking at a
reasonable house for a guy my at 21
years old i'm gonna get a condo a
townhome a two three bedroom home in
columbia missouri that's i don't know
what are they running over there 250 300
i don't know the price points yeah yeah
anywhere between there three three up
you know okay now you could do this with
cash and i think if you wanted to wait
five years you could do that there's not
a need to do that because you could go
ahead and do this with a great strong
down payment of you know 50 to 100 grand
in the next year or two
and then that house will appreciate and
you'll have a very reasonable mortgage
payment that's no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage and that puts you in
a really strong financial position to
pay it off early and become a
millionaire which you told me you wanted
to be earlier
yes sir that's been the goal that's what
that's what's got me here today you're
on the path man you keep at it but i
don't know this five year goal i think
you can do better
there's no you're a sharp young man no
need to shout at you george
i mean with that though george what
should i just keep putting my money into
the checking and savings thing i would
put it in a high yield savings account
online you'll get about one and a half
percent right now and that's just fine
because i think that's not gonna be five
years in which case i'd tell you to
invest it but this looks more like a one
or two year deal to me ken yeah well boy
if you keep pushing him probably will be
i'm i'm my goodness listen i'm ready to
run through so much pressure
young man to buy something just crushing
it i'm proud of him no you're doing that
was wonderful jordan folks this is why
we call them the george campbell this is
the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me this
hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're helping you win
financially we'll help you win
professionally help you win relationally
uh george and i teaming up today on
money and work calls your greatest
wealth building tool is your income
thank you george
our dream team that's right so we're
talking about working money so if you
want to upgrade the gig
uh get out of a toxic dead-end situation
i'll help you with that today and george
is here of course
to answer your money questions let's go
to maggie who joins us in chicago
illinois maggie how can we help
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call really glad it's you instead of
dave today because i have a credit card
question hold on a second
on a sec i've never heard a caller say
that before this is fantastic
i want to i want to revel in this for
just one moment
okay that's enough dave are you
listening okay yeah well okay so here's
my question we i know credit cards are
bad i totally get the philosophy behind
it i 100 get that but
all of our main
fixed bills come out the first half of
the month so when we get paid twice a
month
if we pay everything the way we're
supposed to we really don't have money
left
for our day-to-day stuff our groceries
the kids stuff that pops up all that
until
we would get paid the second half of the
month so what ends up happening is we
just kind of put everything on the
credit card do our fixed bills out of
the first paycheck and then credit card
and you know a couple other things out
of the second paycheck so
it works but i know that i could be
saving more money if i wasn't pulling
out the plastic if i had cash for
everything i just can't come up with
enough cash to make that work does that
make sense
it does but this is just a budgeting
issue yeah and you need a little buffer
in the checking account and then we need
to start budgeting for those bills we
know when they're coming in and you can
actually call a lot of these companies
and set a certain date of the month when
you want to pay those bills i also
wonder uh maggie before you respond to
george on that is this also an income
issue
no i mean we're fine we're debt-free
we're working on paying off the house
early um i just think it's kind of set
up in a way and
i i mean i just i've always done the i
do the bills so i've always just kind of
done the credit card and then just paid
that off instead of and i do take cash
out i should say that too um like the
first of the months when we get paid
that's going to be the mortgage and um
you know the insurance that we put aside
and
those kind of things and then i do take
out like
i take out cash for groceries i take out
cash for um you know some cash but i
feel like i always there's always
something that i'm putting on the credit
card anyway whether it's you know the
kids my kids are in sports so it's like
oh well you know we just lost my
football gloves at practice okay we
gotta run out to dicks and get more
batting or um you know football gloves
or you know there's always something
that i end up so it sounds like there's
things outside of the budget that catch
you off guard it's not built because you
said there's certain things what i do is
i have yeah and i have a bunch of um
like sinking funds so then i will just
transfer like we have a kid's account so
you know we put the money in the kids
account and if i if i have to buy those
gloves and i'll transfer money over but
i still i just feel like as
well as i think we're doing with money i
feel like i still have that problem
where if i didn't have
the credit card
as kind of a catch-all that we would be
you know stuck in you know certain times
of the month well it sounds like this
credit card has become a crutch and a
safety blanket yeah so i think if we cut
that bad boy up and we have a little bit
of buffer in our checking account when
we start to get this budget dialed in we
figure out when the bills are coming in
and we use our previous income to pay
for future expenses that would solve all
of these problems right
yeah so how does that work because you
know we kind of do the zero my husband
always wants to put a little extra in
the checking account for that reason but
then i feel like if there's extra in
there then we're to go through it
when we should be at a zero base well
you need some check zero base doesn't
mean you have zero dollars in your
checking account it means that you've
assigned every dollar a job as far as
your income goes so you definitely need
to have a buffer in your checking
account maybe that's 500
maybe it's a thousand dollar buffer in
there uh but again that's on you of
self-discipline to go we're not going to
touch it a thousand dollars is basically
zero
that is our that's our starting point
and i think that will help you alleviate
some of these uh credit card habits to
go spending and make sure junior doesn't
lose his glove
well you can't do that jordan i mean
come on yeah they're 13 year old boy i'm
i'm over it thank you she's done with
that guys
for the next five years i feel your pain
it's on him to pay for that yeah well
there you go george like she can't
control that he's you know he's got a
much better life lose one glove shame on
me lose two shame on you yeah well
maggie george has no kids okay he
doesn't understand the pain that you and
i are dealing with i understand personal
responsibility oh do you yeah do you
we'll see how you understand that when
your kid loses everything
uh anyways maggie i think this is this
is part budgeting issue
and it's part a scheduling issue
figuring out when the bills are coming
in so if you know those bills are
catching you off guard let's schedule
them and say hey electric company i want
to pay on the 15th yeah instead of the
fourth yeah and you can settle
my husband got he we went from a first
and fifteenth to his company switched to
every other
week which has totally been throwing a
wrench in the works because to try and
you know we have our money that goes out
you know into savings a certain time
every month and that's become
an issue because if he gets paid one day
later it's like oh now i gotta go back
and change well you guys are debt-free
so why not have one month full of
expenses ready to go in the checking
account that way you're not stressing
about if you're going to have enough and
so that can be a budgeting strategy that
helps a lot of folks to be a whole month
ahead so you're not wondering if you're
going to have enough but again the
better strategy is to do a rock solid
budget use your previous income from
that check is going to pay the future
expenses yeah and i don't want the
audience
to miss what george said
because it's really true it's a simple
little hack
most companies will work with you if you
just call them up and go hey i'm going
to put this on autopay they love that so
you've already got them at that point so
here's my debit card let's auto pay but
instead of hitting me on the fourth of
the month or the third i'd like you to
hit me on the 20th or the 18th if i
could pay you know they'll work with you
on that stacey and i've had to do that
multiple times because the way we get
paid here as well it's just kind of like
hey and it's fine they'll work with you
and that way you get things a little bit
more uniformed uh and laid out that way
so that's that's a great hack and a lot
of them let you do it on your own online
so look into that if not give them a
call yeah email them whatever you gotta
do i i you strike me as a guy who has
everything on it 100
like you get you get a text all the time
going mr campbell you've just paid your
electric bill yes now it's twofold i put
it on autopay but i don't just let it go
and not know what my bills are so i get
the email yeah i put everything on
paperless because you know me i'm a
millennial i don't want i don't want a
paper what do i do with this paper i
don't know you really you really haven't
got it right
yeah not here even the papers on the
desk stresses me out
so i i get the email so i know what the
bill is
so that i don't do that george oh i
can't stand it that's the best of the
paper all of america wants you to stop
doing that i don't know i think the
people in the lobby are laughing they
like the sound of the paper crinkling
it's a win we gotta mention
putting things on autopilot on autopay
doesn't mean we're not paying attention
i think that's right good so we have to
know hey what's your system the bill was
twice as much this month you don't want
that to sneak up so do you get an email
every time that's what i was saying you
get an email or text that's what i was
assuming you exactly so the electric
bill i get the email at the end of the
month saying hey here's what the bill's
gonna be and i go cool that sounds about
right and it's on autopay so i don't
have to think about it i don't have to
get you know one of those late
collection bills in the mail not dealing
with that so i'm a big fan of auto pay
but you got to pay attention still yeah
yeah and i think when you hear that
phone call like that you know that
sometimes people just feel like they
they have to play by everybody else's
rules
and you know you don't have to because
companies want to get paid your your
system is broken and i talked with our
friend craig rochelle about this on the
entree leadership podcast recently
it's time for a new system yeah and that
means replacing the old broken system
and the old bad habits and replacing it
with good healthy habits and that might
mean having a buffer in the checking
account it may mean scheduling your
bills to hit on a certain day right and
it's those simple little things that
really give you confidence in the plan
and go oh i can do this thing i don't i
can cut up the cards i don't need them
they were a crutch they were a safety
blanket so if that's you america i agree
it's time for a new system well and the
theme here the is is underneath all of
this is that you can control certain
things take control of what you can
control and you can control your budget
you can control your planning you can
control the date by which you pay the
bills these are all things that you can
control uh that's that's really the
ramsay message at its core i mean it is
it is it really can take control yeah
you got this i'm curious that when your
electric bill spikes is because of the
uh incessant hair drying
if you have more than one shower in the
day that's about four minutes a day ken
yeah you know little things about george
that you find when you go on a retreat
with him he dries his hair with a blow
dryer before going to bed hey this
volume doesn't just happen on its own
ken yeah his room wasn't his room kelly
was next to mine he's blow-drying his
hair to let's not talk about your
snoring ken that's a whole another topic
well that was your hair dryer
oh boy this is the ramsey show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you win
in your financial life your professional
life and your relational life i'm kent
coleman george campbell is my
co-host he's my colleague here's a
personality the number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five i'll warn you
george and i like to have fun
uh so you know we we might just laugh a
little bit with you we may laugh at you
we may laugh at each other which by the
way we like to laugh at each other don't
take it personally can people get
offended they go wow ken and george are
really there's some beef there they say
this there's no beef they don't say that
no no one's ever said no because there's
no beef they'll make stuff oh beef we
like hanging out we actually vegan
that's how little beef there is
see i had to go ruin it i was really
liking the direction we were going but
no we had dinner together the the
colemans and the camels that's true it
was a great time stacy is incredible and
i know you're a big fan of whitney my
wife
yeah i thought you were saying stage is
incredible you're not so much you were
there too i was there stacy is
incredible and i was just there but it
was george's favorite restaurant and i
got to tell you folks trust george when
he makes a food recommendation when i
make any recommendation i don't make
them lightly i don't know about
everything oh but that was a great great
restaurant uh leslie joins us as we
start this hour off in yuma
arizona i like saying that word i'm not
gonna lie to you leslie how can we help
hello dave um thank you for taking my
call
um
we
want to build um a four unit apartment
complex
and with the current market and the
prices
uh for
these things have been uh getting
up and down and
we just don't know if it's a good time
for us to build right now
um or if we should wait
so why do you want to build a fourplex
um well we
already own
um
a small commercial building that's being
rented
in a little smaller town and
um it has some land on the back and we
see it as an opportunity to build there
we already have the four the floor plans
we paid around eighteen thousand dollars
and
we just don't know whether we should
wait or
okay so is this is this strictly an
investment property or do you plan on
living there
no no we we already have a house um is
it paid off do you have a mortgage on it
um
yes uh we currently owe like 310 000
for the house and then for the
commercial
um
building which is currently being rented
we owe
um 97 000 okay and then we owe 25 000 uh
for a car
okay
what's this four plex gonna cost
uh around 360 000
and how much are you going to put down
on that
um they're telling us that
they need around 25
equity but they can continue the same
property they'll do a like uh
one loan and they'll take into account
their equity
okay well leslie i got to tell you to me
this plan sounds like a nightmare
because you're sitting here with
hundreds of thousands of dollars in debt
and then planning on going hundreds of
thousands more in debt with nothing down
with multiple
mortgage payments to pay with car loan
debt so i mean if you're following the
ramsey plan we're going to pay cash for
any investment properties and we're
going to do that once our current home
is paid for
and so we are not we're not in the
business of nothing down real estate and
you know we want to do it the smart way
and if you've heard dave ramsey's story
you'll know that he's he's done done
with uh with some zeros on the end and
went bankrupt because he got a little
fancy with his real estate deals and
that's what i'm worried for you guys is
putting yourself in a financial bind
going further into debt with those four
plex because you're talking you're going
to be close to a million dollars in debt
by the end of this
yes well we both make over 200 000
dollars and we don't know anything other
than the house
the house is worth around uh 500 000.
so everything you just heard george said
bounced right off of you because you
think well we make over 200 000 this is
a good move for us so i just want to
push you heard what george said we're
not going to change our opinion on this
we don't want anybody to go into debt
but i just want to try to make a
financial case by asking you a question
what do you what do you think you're
going to make what do you guys plan to
clear
on the fourplex let's just run the
numbers what do you think your mortgage
is going to be or what have they told
you it is and what do you think you're
going to clear on it
well
we think the mortgage is going to be
around 20
100
plus
water repairs insurance in taxes um
we're thinking we
are going to have like around 905
that's what you're going to clear each
month is 900
yes so we're gonna go hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt
to clear 900 a month
yes does that make sense to you you're
going to pay more than that interest
alone on this deal which is going to be
higher because it's an investment
commercial loan
so i i just don't feel good about this
no i know i know we don't i mean i'm
leslie i'm i'm putting you on the spot
on purpose does that make sense to you
when you look at the risk versus reward
it's a simple risk reward question
to risk all of that debt
to clear 900 a month does that seem like
a good risk reward
scenario for you
well the way i saw it is that the
apartments they were they were gonna get
paid with the rent so
that would be
in addition to
having those apartments being paid on
their own
there's no such thing as a free lunch
lesley and one thing goes wrong the roof
the hvac a renter doesn't pay and you
got four renters now there's a lot more
to worry about a lot there's four times
as many complaints and issues and
repairs and maintenance and this just
scares me having a million dollars in
debt now you can do whatever you want
and you guys might just be fine but man
following the ramsey plan you got to be
out of consumer debt we're going to get
an emergency fund we're going to pay off
the current house our primary residence
we're going to be investing for the
future and i think right now truthfully
you're starry eyed looking at the just
napkin math of well what if we built a
fourplex and what would it do for us
financially you guys are doing great
financially let's utilize this income to
pay off our debt then how much faster
can we save up and pay cash for
investment properties and do it the
right way with very little risk that's
what i want for you guys
yeah george what is the what's the pull
i mean she's she's a smart lady but
there's always a pull on this you know
it's like
well in the real estate investment world
ken and you've seen this time and time
again there can be a little bit of that
greeting like you just look at the
numbers and go oh my gosh we could be
making so much money and it looks great
on paper until reality hits and they
call on the show and says hey my renter
hasn't paid in six months and they trash
the place and the hvac's out we owe on
our current mortgage we have a car loan
we have 97 000 on the other property and
you feel the weight and the stress
and we're all about financial peace
around here we're trying to simplify
our life especially financially and when
you have debt hanging all around you and
you get starry-eyed at a real estate
investment that's where things can go
south and we've seen it time and time
again here on the show and i don't want
that for leslie's future yeah and we
don't want it for anybody folks it's
just very simple that all that risk
uh boy i'll tell you it's not the sexy
advice to say pay cash for investment it
really isn't no
not when you got a bunch of loudmouths
posing in front of private jets on
instagram and the bank says you can do
it over leverage and
yeah it's just a trap it's so risky and
it's just so destructive if it doesn't
work
all right folks we are continuing on
here in just a few moments quick break
right back
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman george campbell my colleague
joins me this hour we are so excited
that you are here we're also excited to
be back on the road
uh with the rising cost of everything
these days a lot of folks are worried
about having enough money in their bank
accounts
uh just to get through the month the
good news is no matter where you are
with your money today no matter the
state of the economy you can get on a
path of building wealth at our building
wealth live events you'll learn a simple
common sense
group of principles to build real
lasting wealth the tour is really fun we
had a spring
uh leg and now we are out this fall
on a
leg going out west if you will uh
phoenix we start in september 12th is a
brand new date our september 13th date
in phoenix is already sold out so we
added another day
of sacramento november 1st sold out
minneapolis november 10
in san antonio november 15th you can get
your ticket starting at 25
or you can get a four pack starting at
60
go to ramsey solutions
ramseysolutions.com
events that's ramsay solutions.com
events to reserve your seats now uh
john delaney and i do a little pre-show
thing we talk about love and work right
work and relationships and then uh he
and i joined the panel
the illustrious panel that's being
recalled yes with uh dave ramsey who
teaches for an hour and then uh rachel
cruz our dear friend
uh
kind of leads the panel with dave you
uh me and john it's a good time you get
you get what five of us up there it's a
party it is it is a great talk from dave
ramsey as well on building wealth and
get rich quick and all the things he's
seen with his perspective over 30 years
of doing this stuff it's eye-opening
it's encouraging you're going to leave
going i can be a millionaire yeah i can
do this stuff regardless of what's
happening in the economy or the white
house yeah so get your ticket bring some
popcorn and join us it's gonna be a lot
of fun
uh manuel uh is joining us is that right
am i reading the screen properly george
we're traveling to tokyo i love this
this is an international show tokyo
japan is where he joins us how can we
help hi thank you for taking my call you
bet what's going on
uh mainly uh well as you might have
guessed from my location i studied
japanese in college and that took my
career out out to the far east and
currently i work for a japanese firm
and it's a great it's a great company i
have no problem
working with them however as i look to
the future
uh you know you never know what's going
to happen with this this company and i'm
in the business world but the the
thought of changing jobs is really scary
to me because i don't have a degree in
business i have a degree or a
a stem field degree i have a degree in
chapter in the japanese language
i don't know uh
you know
if experience is is more important here
i need another degree to get my foot in
the door if i ever
want to change jobs but uh i'd like some
advice yeah sure are you thinking about
changing jobs
uh sometime in the near future or are
you just thinking way ahead and going
what if i get tired of what i'm doing
now and i've got this specialty area and
i'm just wondering what's driving this
call
right so the company is actually uh
planning to send me back to the states
in three to five years but it's it's as
you say it's it's more of a long-term
thing i don't have any plans to leave
this company but what do you do for them
now
all right so they're a a contract
manufacturer and i'm in the sales
department
okay so you're more of an account
manager okay so you're an account
manager
um and uh i'm assuming you're leveraging
your degree and your ability to speak
japanese fluently or no
yes yes that's that's the main reason
they hired me is because the uh the
production
uh is all conducted in japanese so to
speak with their american clients they
needed somebody like me okay and when
you set out to get this major in this
focus
what was your early vision why did you
choose this because this is a very
specific choice i'm just curious what
was driving that
well i was i was good at it and
uh i got straight a's with all my
chinese classes and i thought you know
if i'm good at it i might as well keep
going down this road and uh you know
here i am today yeah well and i think
what's happening and this is a good
thing what's happening is you're now
realizing talent's not enough aren't you
you're kind of like
i'm good at it
but
there's something else out there i know
there's something else out there you may
have some specific ideas you may not
but i teach on the ken coleman show and
here on the ramsay show the idea of how
do i find a purpose in my work how do i
answer the question what should i do
with my life when it comes to work and
the combination is manual i use what i
do best talent
to do work that i enjoy that's passion
to produce results that matter to me
mission
and i think what you're starting to
realize is you've got the talent
linguistically right and certainly
you've been able to master the japanese
language and it's gotten you a really
good job
but now you go okay that's just a skill
set what do i enjoy to do and i think
you're beginning to see that you're
starting to go oh how would i pivot am i
right
uh well i do enjoy my job it's it's more
or less security in the future right now
i understand but my point is is what do
you want to do i mean there's got to be
something up the ladder you you have
much bigger vision than just being an
account manager in sales
true
well i stumped you on that one okay well
that's fine but but that's part of how i
answered this question
for you to come up with ideas on what
you want to do long term you've got to
get to the other two parts of that that
that equation i gave you talent plus
passion plus mission you got to start to
identify what do i really enjoy doing
you know who are the people i enjoy
helping how do i like to help them and
so this is a beginning of a process for
you and i'm going to give you a couple
tools here i'm going to give you my get
clear career assessment i want you to
take it it's about a 20-minute
assessment it's going to give you
detailed report on talent passion
admission and fill out a purpose
statement for you to where you go okay
now this becomes a filter
for what i would do long term okay and
i'll give you my book from paycheck to
purpose which will unveil the seven
stages you'll take long term but to give
you the advice today for you to begin to
think about this you've got to be able
to say all right
what could i do
before you come up with what should i do
okay and i just think you're early in
your career and you know i don't want to
put you on the spot
but are you tracking with what i'm
telling you
yeah i have a long more of a long-term
vision where i want to see myself in 10
20 years that's it
that's the exploration and it's fun it
doesn't need to be intimidating george
yeah and it's beginning to visualize
what could i do what would i enjoy doing
where do i want to do it and even if you
want to continue to be an account
manager do you not think you could go to
another company and get an account
manager job with the degree that you
have
with your experience so i've been i've
been looking at the you know the
different jobs uh job postings and most
of them have as a requirement that you
have a four-year degree in business or a
related field so that's kind of truly i
think they're gonna see past that when
they go wow this guy has some incredible
experience clearly he knows what he's
doing he's great at this job and they're
gonna overlook that piece of the
requirement you work for an
international or multinational company
yes they don't care if you have a
business degree i'm just telling you not
with the amount of experience three to
five years from now if you're going to
stay with this company another two three
years that's all the experience you need
companies all around the world certainly
the united states will be happy to hire
you you're gonna have tremendous
experience you do not need to go get
another degree
are you good at children are you good at
your job
i like to think so yeah great then
you're gonna be able to find another one
doing just that and can i ask you
it's 4 30 in the morning in tokyo did
you wake up just to call us
yes i did yeah there it is well i just
respect that and i really want to pay it
off listen
the degree question is always going to
come down to this i've got to know where
i want to go
okay professionally and then i have to
ask is a degree
the only way i can get there
and then the second question is is a
degree the best way to get me where i
want to go but right now
young man you just don't know where you
want to go and that's okay
there's no problem with that but you
don't have a mountaintop that you've got
in your mind so the degree is an
automatic no there's no sense in getting
a degree when we don't know where we
want to go right now you're doing really
great you're in a good company you're
building your platform how old are you
i'm 28 years old yeah you're 28 right
man the 20s are all about exploration
and experimentation professionally and
beginning to see and your 30s is when
you begin to build your 40s and 50s is
when you harvest so you're in good shape
young man hang on the line i do want you
to take the get clear career assessor to
really help you with clarity and some
confidence moving forward we'll also
give you the companion to that
from paycheck to purpose the book that
gives you the seven stage process
to actually get your dream job
appreciate the call wow it's really
early george that's amazing really early
it's that kind of effort that's got him
to where he is today this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me this
hour we're here to help you win
in your
money your
work your profession and in your
relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to knoxville tennessee
uh harrison joins us there how can we
help sir
hey guys thank you so much for all you
do thank you sir
all right so i just got a new job here
in tennessee with uh tva all right so
we're uh me and my wife are
renting right now because we're just
kind of waiting we we did purchase land
but we couldn't really afford um
just the building prices like it was
just out of our budget right now we're
just renting
so my question is
should i
rent
or sell the home that i had in south
carolina that we moved from
what are you doing with it now i'm
right now it's just it's vacant
oh that's not fun
why do you want to rent it so
um because it's in a fantastic area that
area is really blowing up
and um how much do you owe on that house
i owe 168 000 and the interest rate is
2.8 percent oh nice what's it worth
um one realtor quoted that we could get
anywhere conservatively 250 000 and then
possibly up to 270 000.
now you guys said that you have this
land you're not doing anything with it
as well on top of that
that's correct do you owe money on that
for that
i'm completely debt free
um except for the house
except for this house in south carolina
that's correct okay i know a dave would
say george well
my goal is for you to get a house
and so that means i'm selling this one
because that's going to expedite the
process to get a down payment
and if it's a hot area that means it's
going to sell for a pretty penny yeah
i'm telling you right now uh dave i can
hear him in my head right now going
don't be a long distance landlord don't
be a long distance landlord you know
it's just a pain
in the you-know-what you know and george
is right
that fast forward is a lot of stuff for
you
correct
my in-laws have experience with a
company that handles that and so i did
talk to them they had great reviews and
they estimated i get 1400 to 1500 a
month if i did rent
but what do you owe on it every month
uh 900
yeah so we're doing this for a few grand
a year
that's if everything goes perfectly
so i'm selling this thing i'm going to
use that money as my future down payment
on top of saving up what's your new
income
uh it rains it's around 80 to 90 000 a
year
so making 80 to 90 000 a year debt free
you should be able to sock away a good
chunk of money on top of the sale
proceeds from this house and you can get
in a house in the next year or two
in your area
yes that sounds probably about right
that would be my plan especially as
homes continue to appreciate over the
next five ten years especially in your
area that would be my plan in ballpark
george what do you think he puts down on
the next house knowing what he could get
on this house uh well if you're saying
you can sell it for 250 and you owe 168
um that's going to put you at about you
know 84 grand or so and then you
probably sock away out of that 90 000
you're making you could probably save
another 30 000 in the next 12 months
which gives you a six figures to put
down on your next property for your
primary residence
right that puts you in a good financial
think about that and lowering your
expenses
i just i think your in-laws are telling
you and you respect them and i
understand why but i think your in-laws
are trying to talk you in
to
uh renting this house but george said it
beautifully
talk about a couple thousand dollars a
month after you pay your mortgage a year
yeah a year excuse me a year thank you
that's just
i don't care if you got a man a company
managing it for you or not it's still a
pain in the butt for a couple grand a
year i just think you have to really
look at that what's the benefit for that
versus
the 80 000 getting you started on a
fantastic down payment
and think about how long it would take
you to save up eighty thousand dollars
out of your own income yes a very good
point so i like this i like this plan
you can do your plan but man this one
sounds a lot more peaceful to me i'd
sell it
i can't you know ken and i we're big
fans so there's like i like to sell
stuff there's a big you know uh
the feeling is why would you ever get
rid of a rental you can make so much
money
let's look at the numbers there's not a
lot of money to be made on this thing i
agree and the hassle of it so yeah i
agree that's just one man's opinion
there it is mary lou is up in saint
louis missouri mary lou how can we help
yes thank you for taking my call sure
my husband and i are both retired and we
recently sold a piece of rental property
for 150 000
and we're just wondering which is the
best way to invest it
awesome so you have 150 000 sitting in
the bank right now
yes awesome it's in money market okay
what give us a little snapshot of your
financial picture what do you guys have
in retirement do you have any debt do
you have an emergency fund and what's
your income
we don't have any we don't have any debt
we have a emergency fund of probably
60 000
um and our income is probably 55 a year
okay and what's in retirement
uh we've got about a hundred thousand
probably or not got more than that i'm
sorry um we're in that we have
investments with uh edward jones uh
probably four hundred thousand okay and
do you owe on your primary residence
no we don't we're not in any debt at all
we we have been blessed that's that's
great news and so really you don't have
any current plans that you need to make
with this hundred fifty thousand dollars
no renovations no car upgrades nothing
big that you're trying no nothing we no
we don't we just don't know what to do
with it we it's just laying there you
know we would like to invest in some way
sure well if you're going to use it in
the near future let's say three to five
years you could park it in an s p 500
index fund if you're wanting to purchase
property in the future are you wanting
to get back into some real estate
investing
no actually we're 82 we're both 82 years
old and we've we've been there done that
and we just want to keep what we have
well that's great news in that case if
you're just saying hey we want to want
this to create income for us long term
use the power of compound growth you can
invest it in some great growth stock
mutual funds and if you need help
choosing the right ones you can connect
with one of our smart investor pros at
ramseysolutions.com
and they're gonna help you make the best
use of that hundred fifty thousand
dollars because even at you know let's
say ten percent growth well that's
fifteen grand a year that's compounding
for you versus sitting in that money
market making nothing
right right so i like that plan a whole
lot but you guys have done so well i'm
proud of you guys
well we we have been blessed we have a
large family we have when we all get
together there's 30 of us though wow
well you might need to carve out some of
that money for the catering you might
have a few astro vans to transport
everyone
that's right well we we have been
involved in in touch with that as well
i'll bet well mary lou that is so great
uh definitely if you've not connected
with one of our smartvestor pros ramsay
solutions.com click on the smart
investor pro tab uh an interview for a
few folks uh in your area don't just let
this money sit yeah yeah they'll help
you maximize this
and uh what what an awesome blessing
this is so congratulations i like mary
lou ken just so peaceful i want to hang
out with her after the last call are
wondering well i don't want to sell a
rental and now you hear mary lou going
we sold the rental feels great
she's 82. she said we've been there done
that she's like that's for the whipper
snappers that's right we're chilling but
there's a great teaching moment there
because mary lou has options
oh boy when you call in and you go we
got a big she's got 150 000 options we
have no debt no mortgage what do we do
yeah that's an exciting problem to have
versus being backed into a corner going
we've got a huge pile of debt we've got
all these properties all these mortgages
what do we do yeah it's a very different
tone yeah and i'm proud of her yeah that
is awesome stuff i love to hear it that
is just that is great you know 82. it's
impressive
i hope you make it that long ken i think
you will you think so yeah i appreciate
it i think people who golf just tend to
live longer
and you've been out there on the course
this morning
well you know
somebody's got to do it you know i find
it to be i find it to be tremendous
therapy if i'm being honest yeah what do
you do george what's your heart golf
golf is very stressful what do you do
i play guitar i just watch some stand-up
comedy that's what's doing some good
music yeah so play with my dogs okay
dogs are therapy to me ken you seem very
lonely
that's for the doctor john delaney show
i'll be calling in soon okay well we can
hang out after the show today
i'll sit there and watch you play your
guitar thank you i need an audience that
feels pathetic
all right tell cody where more of your
calls coming up next this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show where we
help you win with your money
your work and your relationships
uh we've been talking years off about
how real estate market uh is not gonna
crash
and how though we are in a mini
recession it's not the end of the world
well here's some more good news mortgage
rates dropped more this past week
than they have in any week since 2020.
so george we're seeing that we're seeing
the roller coaster of the mortgage rates
right oh yeah and um
they're only down by by about point
three percent but
uh you can celebrate this win by
refinancing or buying the house you've
been wanting remember that making
decisions based on facts not fear pays
off in a changing market so if you're
taking this dip in mortgage rates as
your chance to buy a home like other
people are make sure you're ready make
sure you have an experienced real estate
agent by your side
to walk you through it if you want to
talk to one that's ramsey trusted go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent those pros from our endorsed local
providers program are top of the line
and know
how to help you
through the market changes again that's
ramsay solutions.com
agent ramsey solutions.com agent georgia
you and whitney yes just went through
this process recently took advantage got
yourself a good deal and let me tell you
our agent
was fantastic and he gave us some great
gifts oh is that right i got a giant
yeti cooler
and a roomba as a whole what else what's
a roomba one of those little robot
vacuums oh did you really yeah do you
use it or about to
just run it just roams around the house
gets rid of all that dog hair well i'm
not even home oh that's a blessing and
doesn't bump into the furniture no it's
smart ken you don't have one don't
change your family george i just asked
you live on the air what aruba is of
course i don't have i thought you were
playing coy no no i'm genuinely
interested you're the you're my friend
who has the cool stuff like you teach me
stuff all the time
you're like i appreciate that i learned
stuff from you well you know the gen gen
x they missed out on all the hot tech
and us millennials we took full
advantage ah there it is i'll get you
there i'm here for you yeah uh but you
got the yeti cooler too it's my first
one because i'm never going to spend 400
on a cooler well you could sleep in that
thing oh absolutely yeah and i guess in
an ice bath i don't know what i'm doing
in there yeah cold plunge no thank you
yeah i like that trevor's up in chicago
illinois trevor how can we help hey
how's it going guys you guys are awesome
love you guys oh thank you very much we
love you trevor we're going to send you
a
five dollar bill for that public comment
i'm kidding it's a joke i'm not going to
send you anything he's going to be
reaching out to you say that then mommy
five nights no i was joking i don't mean
that what's your question trevor all
right
i really need your help um i'm on i'm on
step six
kind of
oh now hold on
hold on
how are you kind of on baby step six
what does that mean okay all right i was
gonna i wasn't gonna get into this but
i'll tell you so we got to step two
skipped over step three
four and five and paid off our house
so you have no you have no emergency
fund you've not been saving 15 that's
baby step four you didn't fund anything
for college you just went to the house
yeah we so we did step one step two we
did step six yeah then we did step three
oh
now now we're now we're past step four
and we're on step fives that's one way
to do it wow
okay
all right and here's the here's the deal
so i'm at basically savings for college
and and then i'm on step seven
and no more literally lost
zero mortgage payment and now we're just
funding college and building wealth and
being generous
yeah so technically your baby steps
seven
technically yeah yeah you are the most
confused debt-free person i've ever met
that's a compliment it's fantastic the
way you just laid that out i think
you're exhausted i think you're mentally
exhausted
just walking through that scenario
that's why i'm calling because i'm just
totally not a gazelle anymore well you
don't have to be
oh i feel like i blew your mind there i
think i heard trevor's feeling i think
the smoke is coming no no no no you
don't have to be gazelle intense anymore
am i right george yeah we we move from
intense to intentional once we uh are in
baby step four and beyond i got a slow
and trevor you've been very intentional
right
yeah so what are you beating yourself up
for why don't you feel like you're
intense enough
i guess because of the ambiguity of what
college is going to be for my kids by
the time they get to that age
what's your plan
what's your plan how much you plan to
save
we don't have a plan right now how many
kids do you have
three how old are they
six nine and eleven
okay when you say you don't have a plan
are you putting anything aside every
month
you said you were what are you putting
away yeah
we've got savings accounts for each of
the kids
are they esa's or 529s
they're no they're just regular savings
accounts i guess our focus is to
since we're not at the 15 we're doing 10
percent on step four why
so
you don't have any payments
i'm con do you not have enough money to
invest fifteen percent it's
well our kids are in private school and
it's kind of or we're tight right now
i get it
so but i guess my point is is it it's
like it blew your mind when i told you
you didn't have to be gazelle intense
technically you really don't right now
but you do have to be investing 15
yeah at least yeah if you put something
away for college that's bonus
so do not sacrifice your own retirement
to send junior off to college
right
i agree with that because they're going
to be supporting mom and dad once
they're out of college and we don't want
that is there a question in there
because you ran us through a really fun
exercise of how you did the baby steps
it was like a it was like a twister
board
uh is how you went about doing it what
what do is there a question that we
haven't answered
i guess one my biggest question is am i
going to have enough for retirement and
that's kind of the thing that how old
are you i lose
42. how much do you have in retirement
now
200 000. okay yeah you're gonna be fine
if you're gonna work another what 15 20
years
23 years yes you've got that planned out
you're not that lost that's the quickest
answer you've had all this entirely and
what's your house worth
250 000
okay yeah and so you've got it
you've got about a half million dollar
net worth
does that sound right
yeah okay so the next five years
to 10 years you'll be a baby steps
millionaire
and 10 years after that you're gonna
have multi-million dollars in your
accounts
and with your home appreciation
you're gonna have enough you're gonna be
fine but you do need to get that number
up to 15 yeah and then whatever's left
over and if private school is holding
you guys back from being able to retire
with dignity we need to re-look at
private school
and go is this the right option for us
right now
right
because how much is private school
costing you guys
1500 a month
ouch
i don't know how you paid off a mortgage
and now you're tight after not having
that payment anymore what's your
household income
a hundred thousand a year
okay i wanna i want you guys to look at
that budget and do an audit and going
where are we overpaying do we need to
check up on our insurance do we need to
really ratchet down on eating out do we
need to cut some subscriptions and do we
need to get more income in the door i
think if you do all those things you
need some margin in your life especially
to be a baby step seven that's what this
whole plan is about financial peace and
you don't have it right now and that's
where i'm wondering where all these
money leaks are coming from
yeah
well the hunt well the the house was
paid off from the savings account it
wasn't really the debt snowball it was
in savings already we just chose to pull
it out of savings and kill the house
debt
okay
does that make sense so that that's
probably why part of that was confusing
but
i i'm with george i i don't know why you
have the fear
um i'm not sure what's going on but it
just a good old-fashioned
uh you know get in the old sandbox of
the budget and look at everything
because with the money you're making
even with the fifteen hundred dollars a
month going into 18 grand
you make 100 i don't know where the rest
is going when you don't have payments
got plenty to be able to invest 15
percent
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be that
tight so you've done this before
you were unorthodox about it but but you
still have had shown some discipline so
i think it's calls for discipline and
tightening where you need to tighten i
think george is absolutely right
appreciate the call but you're gonna be
fine you're doing better than you think
you are yeah
yeah celebrate
celebrate you sound like igor i want you
acting like tigger right now
that's what i want you're in great shape
man
all right that's uh another hour in the
books george campbell we did it to the
team behind the
the glass that makes it all happen we
love it we love you we love you we love
you and we love you america this is the
ranch
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you win financially
professionally and relationally i'm ken
coleman george campbell is my colleague
and he joins me this hour as we answer
your questions it's a free call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five george will
answer your money questions i'll chime
in
and i'm here to answer any questions
around your world at work you feel stuck
burned out
uh dealing with toxicity want to pivot
want to start a side hustle
you want to get promoted to make more
money i'm your big shovel guy all right
that's what i do over on the ken coleman
show helping people win in their work
and so i want to bring some of that to
the show today
george and i genuinely like uh hanging
out together we sit about uh six feet
away from each other if that if that i
usually butt up a little closer yeah
yeah well you're just trying to bother
you try to get a little bit of wisdom a
little little wisdom uh but anyway we're
having fun today and uh we want to have
fun while helping you so let's go
jared is up in orlando florida jared
you're on excuse me how can i almost
said you see what i did almost wow i
stopped it
hard yeah you do it every day how can we
help jared
hey guys thanks for taking my call um so
i have a car problem uh so i was in the
military several years ago i went
through a about a
two-year period where i went through
five cars and racked up a ton of
negative equity wow what happened
i
uh
was uh you know 21 years old and really
didn't know what i was doing i
bought a car that was about three times
what my salary was with a co-signer at
one point and just kind of spiraled out
of control
um
how old are you now i uh
now i'm not in that situation but um
i'm moving to new york so i no longer
need a car um up still a couple months
ago i was about twenty five thousand
dollars underwater on my uh car car loan
uh now i'm about fifteen thousand um
it's the only debt i have but i'm not
really sure what to do since i have to
move in a month and i can't bring the
car with me uh the car was worth about
thirty thousand
uh as of
about two months ago but i kelly blue
booked it a few days ago and i noticed
it dropped another three thousand so now
i'm wondering
uh
in this kind of short period of time i
have to deal with this do i
either leave it at my parents house and
just keep making payments on it and
throwing more money on it than just a
payment to get rid of it as fast as
possible or do i take out a loan to
cover the negative equity and then just
pay off the loan as fast as possible
my income right now is about 100 000 net
and that's going to be going up to
about 175 000 net uh with salary and
then with bonus it's gonna we're
probably household gonna be clearing
about 270 000 a year so it's going to be
a short term issue uh
in the over the next few months but i
don't have fifteen thousand to throw at
it right now i just have that how much
do you have
uh an emergency fund or just like how
much general cash liquid cash it's just
just a thousand i've been paying off
student loans and everything and that's
all gone this is now the last problem
this is your last final debt
yeah okay so what is the car worth and
what do you owe
the car is worth what kelly bluebic says
is about 27 and i owe about 43 000 on it
ouch
okay and it was like i said it was worse
than that i threw about 10 at it over
the past couple months but uh yeah
that's kind of where i'm at with it yeah
so you're about 15 or 16 000 underwater
yeah i mean your best bet may be and
this is
for america's sake the only time we
would ever tell you to get a loan is
when you are upside down on a car and
you can go to your credit union and get
a loan amount for that amount and pay it
off as fast as possible and it's nice
that you don't need a car because you
don't have to turn around and go buy
another one
yeah so that's a strange blessing in the
situation
do you guys think that it's worth doing
that if i because if my income like i
said is going to be going up to where i
think
at what it's looking like how to
calculate it out it would take me about
two to two and a half months to pay off
the loan that it's error where it's at
right now but i mean
i don't think the interest rate is so
much an issue i mean it's a really bad
interest rate it's eight percent but in
two months you're not going to keep this
car and so there's no real no no need to
go down that path i'd rather you be 16
000 in debt than 43 000 in debt if we
can do that by the end of the week and
then you knock out that debt in a what a
month or two with your income yeah
that's that's what i'm thinking about
about about about two months probably to
knock out a 14 000 loan so that would be
my plan you know how much you owe we're
going to put this upside down car up for
sale we're going to try to get top
dollar for it i'm going to be
you know listing it private on facebook
marketplace and craigslist and
autotrader i'm going to get in touch
with carvana and vroom and dealerships
and see who will give me top dollar for
it so i have the least amount of loan to
take out then we're gonna cover that
upside down amount with a loan from your
credit union or wherever then we're
gonna we don't need another car so
that's a blessing you don't have to deal
with and that will get you out of this
thing in another month or two instead of
months down the road
okay yeah sounds good i think that was
the way i was leaning so i'll do that
thank you yeah thank you that's what we
call a stupid tax ken and uh you know he
he made his mistakes in early on and now
this guy's he's crushing it he's
cleaning up his mess yeah proud of him
yeah i think that's the takeaway for
people that are new to the show and
listening and watching hearing this
story
uh he owned it
he's not defined by it he's digging his
way out of it yeah and a lot of people
carry this shame and guilt and they
don't know what to do and they get
frozen
but the truth is we just put all that
baggage down and we take the right next
step for the future yeah and all right i
made the mistake i'll never make it
again let's move forward and build
wealth yeah i think that's the right
mindset as opposed to you know well i'm
never gonna get out of this well i'm
just gonna have to drag it around it's
fascinating i was thinking the other day
i wanted to ask you this um and i forgot
to ask you this what is the average uh
do you have an idea what the average car
payment americans are driving around
with i know years ago it was about 400.
it's up closer to 600 now is that right
that's the average car payment and the
loan terms are becoming longer and
longer like a 72 months i see yes
and even they'll go longer now i mean
they'll go as long as you want can
they'll just go hey you're gonna be the
seventeen they don't care
because the depreciation is your problem
they're gonna get paid and they're
making interest for a longer period of
time so they're happy about it wow so
don't do it guys yeah what's the going
interest rate on a car line boy that's a
great question i don't know it's not
pretty i'll tell you that much yeah yeah
fascinating yeah so so that's i asked
that question because you know it's
people just i'm seeing uh about three uh
but almost four percent four percent for
new cars
there is still the mindset in america
george it's not gone anywhere no that
like hey you gotta have a car payment
yeah
you know
six hundred dollars a month it's brutal
and these the interest rate can go up
you know as far as 20
on car loans depending on your credit
and what you're coming to the table with
your down payment and all that and so uh
the truth is most people doing that are
buying cards way beyond their means way
beyond their income of course because
they can afford the payment and so we
say stop asking that question start
asking can i afford it in full in cash
instead of can i afford the monthly
payment because that's how broke people
talk and we want you to be wealthy we
want you to be financially free have
peace in your life and when you save up
and you pay cash for a reasonable car
it changes everything yeah like a uh
2013
used tesla that's right that's what you
did exactly i got no one to impress and
yet ken's impressed it's a good-looking
car thank you ken i'm not kidding it's
fantastic
i'll take you for a ride after the show
yeah let's do that i want to do the
thing where you hit the button and it
goes really fast i like that feature oh
i don't know if it's that fancy i have
to look into that all right i'd like to
try that all right don't go anywhere
george and i aren't and we're gonna be
back in just moments to take more calls
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show
i'm ken coleman george campbell joins me
and we are here to answer your phone
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five adam is on the line in
pasadena california adam how can we help
hey guys uh thanks for uh having me i
really appreciate it um
so i'll jump right into it i've been
working for a general contractor for
almost the past 11 years
um and i have two job opportunities
ahead of me
um one is with the city of los angeles
which pays me more and has benefits and
all that stuff or there's another job
with the uh
caltech university in pasadena which is
a couple blocks away from my house
it also pays more but it's kind of in
the middle ground so
what do you mean by middle grade
sorry um
a little nervous guys that's okay you're
doing no no you're doing great i just
didn't know when we compare the the la
jobs city of l.a and caltech you said
both pay more but then you said caltech
is more middle ground i just i didn't
know what you meant
you got it um so right now after taxes
uh i think i took home about 46 000
uh the city of los angeles job as a
carpenter starts at 90 000 a year before
taxes with a pension and benefits
um
and then caltech
is uh 72 8
a year before taxes
uh they don't have a pension they have
more of like a 401k
and that after three years you're in
full control of your money
um so you can kind of choose where they
put it or how much you want to put in
and they also have benefits are you
doing carpentry for both
yes yes i'd be working for the city of
los angeles i would be doing
street services which is far more brutal
than what i do now now i'm a uh
i'm more of a woodworker i do custom
cabinetry woodworking furniture things
of that nature
at caltech i would be kind of doing the
same thing i'm doing now but more in a
uh
a school setting so that'd be building
dorms or
lab tables how old are you cares
maintenance things like that i'm 37 and
i just had a my first son and he's four
months old awesome congratulations
so the reason i asked that much reason i
asked that adam is what's your long-term
play what's the top of the professional
mountain for you as you sit here today
you don't have to hold yourself to this
answer but what's that look like for you
because you're young man so when you're
50 or 45 where do you want to be
professionally
you know i just want to be uh secure and
i know that sounds like a fear thing uh
but
uh
i stayed with the current contractor
that i'm with under the pretense that he
was going to mentor me and i was going
to take over his shop when he retired
that was kind of the carrot in front of
you is that what you wanted is to run
your own shop
it was what i originally wanted but now
what do you want now and don't and i
know you want to be stable so i'm going
to push back
everybody wants to be financially stable
i'm asking you
assume financial stability
what what kind of work would you love to
be doing
over the next five ten years as you kind
of finish out your professional journey
what's the top of the professional
mountain for you
i i mean it would be great to run my own
company although
that's a big hurdle and i've seen a lot
of failures throughout here okay no no
no no i love what i love what i do i
love doing woodwork yeah
that's my point and so here's the deal
it's a crafts right so you love the
craft that you're doing now and so sure
you'd love to own your own business
forget about the fears and the hurdles
if everything were ideal you'd
eventually like to work for yourself in
the space you're in correct
sure okay all i'm trying to do is help
you go all right because we need to know
this when we make decisions like this
the reason i walked you through that
quick exercises is because on paper the
city of la
seems to make more sense
on paper if we just look at well
it's 90 000 versus i'm rounding up 73.
but i don't want you looking at it that
way i want you going okay long term what
do i want to do and for right now we're
not holding you to this but for right
now
it's i want to stay in the craft that
i'm in i'm a craftsman i work with my
hands
and and so i want to be doing that kind
of work and maybe work for myself but i
want to keep moving up so the question
becomes will caltech give you a better
ladder
or will those working for the city of la
give you a better ladder
and i'm removing finances right now i'm
saying what would give you the best
opportunity to continue to advance
i would
i would say the city of los angeles has
more opportunity because it's broader
whereas caltech is a school that is
affiliated with jpl
so that's nice but there's not as much
room to grow a lot of people love their
job there and from the research i've
done tend to stay there for a long time
so it's hard to get say the boss's job
or a promotion right if someone already
is holding that well now the city of los
angeles has several different
departments so you can bounce around
you're still a carpenter but maybe
you're working
you know street services or you might be
working general services you can go to
parks and rec
exactly and
and
because of all of that you just named
think about all the connections you're
making which could lead to some
tremendous private sector opportunities
you're going to be meeting a lot of
people right
sure so i like the city of village
okay okay i appreciate that yeah the one
last thing i was going to say is i live
two blocks away from caltech and
uh
there would be zero commute uh zero
wear and tear on my car zero gas zero
time wealth loss driving my truck um to
and from work every day i mean you know
we're looking at a couple hours every
day
uh you know to and from work at with the
city of los angeles uh so i always take
all those things into account
but
the other thing i wanted to just lastly
ask is
um
you know i i've been with this guy for
11 years and he hasn't done anything to
kind of lift me up there's no more
ladder for me to climb and that's why
i'm leaving but it's it's not without a
heavy heart so sure i just wanted to
make sure
you guys were or maybe get your opinion
that i was on the right path i guess
yeah you are
and and you you have no opportunity to
grow
so you shouldn't feel guilty about
pursuing growth
you're a good guy absolutely could you
move closer to work adam if you took the
city of l.a job
um to be honest i probably could but it
varies so often that which department
they might send you to you it would be
kind of uh you're going all over i don't
yeah yeah i'd be going all over and i've
lived in the same uh rental for the last
like 10 years because i'm really good
with the landlord because i do all the
repairs myself and he hasn't raised my
rent so i like that i would love to i
like that
do all the baby steps i mean i'm not in
debt uh but i don't have anything else
kind of handled other than about five
grand put away well you're about ready
to get a big race listen adam here's the
deal yeah i don't like the commute the
commute sucks there's no way around it
but that's la
so i mean yeah that's part of the deal
you know moving around isn't really an
option because because of the city of
l.a so vast and you might be doing
projects i would take the i would take
the la job
primarily because of the raise
and the connections
because i don't think you're gonna have
to stay with the city of la very long if
you have your head up
and you're making connections you're
talking to people on the job uh that
would be my goal yeah and if a year or
two from now the commute's killing you
and it's not what you thought it was you
can leave yeah i just think you are
stacking connections
big time
uh over the next year two years
so yeah i would take the la city job the
caltech job
it's just gonna it's gonna force your
hand down the road anyway
because you're not gonna have any growth
you've been you've been with a guy for a
long time where there's no ladder and
you know how that feels why would you go
from one ladderless place to another
ladderless place well that's hard to say
george ladderless place yeah but this is
a good point ken if you're a leader out
there and you're not giving your team
members opportunities for growth and
talking about what that looks like
they're going to leave
and that's what we're seeing right now
is people want grow we're designed for
growth and if we're not advancing now
we're not talking about getting a raise
every 10 minutes i'm talking about is
there room for me to grow in this
company long term that's correct and if
you don't have that as a leader they're
going to go find another leader who
cares enough to help them grow george
you're all over it uh in fact the data
backs up your opinion uh
saw an article this week a new study out
the number one reason people left their
jobs over the last six months
they did not feel that they had
professional advancement opportunities
that's not always about money no it's
actually not money because the third
factor was income
they actually want a chance to grow and
do more
we are creatures of progress leaders i
want to make sure that you're answering
that question for people so they don't
want a better job they want a better
life george there it is i want to drink
drop drop my pencil on that one pencil
drop dull move more ramsey show coming
up
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions
worldwide headquarters george campbell
is with me i'm ken coleman we're so
excited that you are with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number to jump in we'll
talk about your work situations you
wanna make more money get out of a toxic
situation figure out what that business
idea is we'll talk about your work and
more money that bigger shovel and then
george is here to answer
your money questions but first we want
you to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
if you use the promo code ramsay to get
the best deal
today's question george comes from alex
in chattanooga i'm 52 000 in debt and
i'm engaged to be married i earn 40 000
a year working at a warehouse and i'm
studying to become a software engineer
which could potentially earn me an entry
level position
starting at 80 000
the software course i'm taking says it
should take six months to complete my
question is
should i put extra free time hours i
have into studying so i can become an
engineer as fast as possible
and double my income in six months or
should i focus on the job i have now put
those extra hours of free time towards
working overtime to save ten thousand
dollars in a year
for our wed uh wedding and then get back
to baby step two after the wedding this
is a true combo question george what do
you think there what what's your your
money advice here well i like the fact
that six months from now he could be
doubling his income i like that a lot
because that means an extra 40k versus
an extra 10k of working overtime but
truthfully the priority right now is we
got to make sure we can cash flow this
wedding get through that completely
debt-free
then we're going to have combined income
hopefully his spouse is going to be
working so we can really tackle this
debt yeah because right now making 40
trying to tackle 52 you're not going to
make a ton of progress no i'm with you
but i'm going to challenge you a little
both and
i'm going with what george says
absolutely focus on the overtime doing
whatever you got to do to cash for the
wedding obviously
but i also think you know what this is
the time to lose a little bit of sleep
so i'm working up late finish this
course getting up early when i'm not
overtime
uh i'm working to get this course done
as well i'd like to cash for the wedding
and have a great job
before i'm married yeah and figure out
the financial aspect of the wedding what
is it going to cost how can we shave
that cost down who's paying for it if
it's just on him and the spouse yeah
that's a different situation versus
family chipping in so have those
conversations to figure out what that
number is you've got to hit by the
wedding date to pay all the vendors and
get married so i borrow a little gazelle
intensity from our baby steps
and i'd put it towards studying hustling
yeah overtime look you're getting ready
to get married so you know she's
planning the wedding she wants you out
of her hair anyway that's true i was no
help i don't know about you either oh
you know but i asked i also told stacey
look babe
i'll go for the registry of the what it
was at the i guess i just said that's
what it is you register for all these
gifts she wanted me there for that so i
was like okay you scan the cake stand
that you'll never use 100
and uh you know i did that
did you know but other than that you
know a couple key questions she wanted
my opinion on
other than that i stayed out of it you
didn't choose the flowers no oh no sad
the key there is
to start your marriage off on the right
foot little relationship advice before
we get into the course
whatever she says she wants or she asks
you hey what do you think of these
flowers
always start with asking another
question what do you think about them oh
that's a life hack because you want to
know is she
you want to be on the road she's really
yes is she really excited about them so
it's always good to go huh what do you
think
because now you look interested
and you look engaged what we're really
doing is trying to figure out which way
we're going
because if she's
then you go hey smart man if she's like
i really like him you gotta go i love
him how many years you've been married
24.
there you go i've not done proof's in
the pudding yeah well hey i made that
mistake recently she bought in
chandelier for the bedroom one wasn't
thinking george came in she hit caught
me off guard
i i wasn't i wasn't prepared she was
what do you think and i was like it's
fine
oh no no no no last words the answer
needs to be
i don't like it
i love it are you scared you had it
in there yeah yeah wow yeah i didn't do
that george i could be all over and see
the new chandelier yeah sure but it's
wonderful i'm gonna tell stacey i don't
like it i love it
there you go oh
brittany is up in indianapolis indiana
brittany how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call um i sold
my house and i'm now living with my
boyfriend i walked away from closing
this week with about 130 000 in cash
whoa
how does that feel
it's amazing
um i have followed all of the baby steps
so now i'm completely debt free
and my question for you guys is what's
the best way for me to invest this money
and most of it i'd like to invest short
term
to have for a down payment on a house in
the future or a wedding or both yeah so
what's the time horizon here are we
talking two years five years
i would think somewhere in that window
of two to five years so i don't know how
strict how strict those timelines need
to be um
well
it depends on your risk tolerance and
when you might need the money because
the fear is a year and a half from now
you go man i really need the money and
the market's down and now you're selling
at a loss
and right brittany here's the question i
have all right george is gonna help you
out on this but but i gotta know
i mean if your boyfriend's on the phone
with this right now is he thinking two
to five years as well because this money
is your money it's not right it's not
our money even though you're you're uh
shacking up with him
it's not his money and i'm just
wondering i i i'm playing the older
brother uh role here george i'm a little
nervous i'm gonna say old man but i like
older brother well either one works i'll
receive it brittany seriously though how
serious is this relationship
uh well we're 30 and we've been dating
for almost three years so i i would say
it's pretty serious um but my dad is
listening i'm sure and he would
appreciate that comment um hey dad
definitely i got your back dad i'm
asking the tough questions today i know
it's serious here three years you've
been together and you think it's gonna
take two more years for this guy to put
a ring on it
i don't think it'll take two years for
an engagement but i'd like to be able to
plan a nice wedding and and everything
like that um i don't think i need a
hundred thirty thousand dollars for a
wedding either you do not you do not my
point is this is your money
until the day you get married you hear
me that's what i want you to i think
your dad wants me to tell you that
absolutely he would appreciate that and
my boyfriend is debt-free besides his
mortgage so i feel like we're in a
really good place okay all right now i
feel like i can get out of the way
george thank you for that ken i'm trying
to help out brittany and britney's dad
and try as you might
yeah so brittany do you uh do you have a
fully funded emergency fund
i do and there's no other current
financial needs upgrades repairs car
upgrades that are in your near future
i don't think so i thought about maybe
upgrading my car but there's nothing
wrong with it so okay well let's leave
that alone for now so if that's the case
if i'm in your shoes i'm probably going
to invest in an s p index fund or some
mutual funds and you can connect with a
smartvestor pro on our website who can
help you navigate all that because that
130 000 you could see it grow at 9 10 11
12
over the next you know three to five
years if you play your cards right which
could really help with this down payment
you might be able to put you know 50
percent down and pay off this house
really fast in your thirties
how cool would that be awesome i love
that so go get connected with one uh you
can interview a few of them and choose
your favorite that you have the best
personal chemistry with you trust the
most to help navigate what to do with
this 130 grand to help it maximize and
grow over the next few years
okay thank you so much hey and i gotta
know what's the what's the guy's name
his name's mike mike needs to commit
mike needs to go shopping for a ring
come on britney if he asked you today
would you say yes
yes yeah i'm telling you we should do an
engagement on air sometime ken that
would be fun you need to send this mike
if you're listening call in and we'll
have brittany on the other line yeah
we'll officiate the whole question
asking i'm sure i'm sure
he got one of those online licenses yeah
i'm just saying like she's ready she's
sharp she's got things going on he said
what's what are we waiting on the
pressure is on mike i gotta tell you i'd
show him this clip because mike i think
it's time for you pal to draw a line in
the sand and tell brittany you want her
to be your wife what are you waiting on
man jeez george this is these guys we're
having a good time i don't know what i'm
doing ken's half joking but mike
seriously call us i know you're
listening if you're dead free and you're
a ramsay fan i'm not joking let's get
mike on get him to call in i'll tell him
how to do a great setup to pop the
question we got to make sure britney's
not listening so that's true you see
what i mean all right folks
more of the ramsay show coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsay solutions worldwide headquarters
just south of nashville tennessee i'm
ken coleman george campbell is with me
our scripture of today uh comes from
proverbs 3 5 and 6 trust in the lord
with all your heart and do not lean on
your own understanding in all your ways
acknowledge him and he will make your
paths straight
our quote of the day from francis chan
our greatest fear should not be of
failure but of succeeding at things in
life that don't really matter
george says
maybe you should start to question your
guitar hobby wow that was a personal
attack friday ken
gosh
no you're wildly talented actually you
got no skills on the sixth string i
think it's jealousy oh 100 but i got no
skills on the golf course i would love
to be able to play the guitar like you
do thank you uh george is very very
talented folks thanks for the club
forget it uh all right cody's up next in
orlando florida cody how can we help
hi ken and george thanks thanks for um
answering my call sorry first call
i'm a little nervous oh you're doing
great we're gonna be so nice to you and
you're going to get great answers i
promise that ken i don't know how i feel
about this all right i'm trying to make
her feel good okay thanks um i just had
a quick question so my husband and i
finally started the baby steps um full
commitment or trying our best um and
we're still in um baby step one
um we only have about 370 dollars saved
so far um we just started this month um
but well we started last month but our
car my car had some pretty bad
maintenance and needed to be worked on
and it's still in the shop
and it's a lot more than what we have an
emergency fund so i'm asking if we
should take some money or really would
be all of it out of our retirement to
cover that cost i know that's
wild but i'm going back and forth just
because it seems like the only other
option
besides selling the car i guess
is taking out a credit card without
interest for the first 60 days so we try
our best work really hard to pay it off
within that time to have no interest and
then just cut up the card but
i don't want to do that still but
i would love to hear your thoughts well
cody the short answer is no the shorter
answer is no
and these are both bad options and i
think you backed yourself into a corner
where you go well my options are uh rob
my retirement or
put it all on a credit card and the
truth is you've got more options than
that so how much is this repair going to
cost
um right now well the estimate a couple
days ago was about
22.52
um but they've since recently found out
that it was worse than they thought when
they finally put the car back together
they said
um so it might be about 100 or 200 more
um i'm still trying to get a hold of
the agent to
get the answer on the total but it's
still in the shop though
is this an engine problem what's going
on
no yeah so um i think this is partially
my fault unfortunately um i i think
they estimate that i was driving with
the emergency brake on without realizing
and that really messed up the brakes the
rear brakes and the calibers and
everything um the calipers go but even
replacing brakes and calipers is not
2500
yeah that's why i was gonna go in and
ask um
why it's a little bit more than i
thought because he did break down
everything in terms of um
individual costs did you go to it like
transmission did you go to it no it's
okay i'm sorry did you go to a dealer
yes but i went thinking i was only
getting a wheel alignment yeah of course
and i would be able to take it to a
dealer cody cody cody what kind of car
is it i didn't know that's okay it's a
honda civic okay do not take it to the
honda dealer
okay so i want you to go get this is
just like a doctor you're gonna go get a
second maybe a third opinion i want you
to talk to everybody you know
i mean everybody you know i'm talking
facebook social media anything everybody
you know church civic clubs everybody go
hey i need a reliable honest mechanic
who do you go to
and let's get one or two options take
the car in if you've got to have it
towed you've got the money it's a small
amount of money but you've got to give
that car over to a honest mechanic do
not tell them
what the dealer charged you just say hey
i need this looked at i need this looked
at and and let's get some other options
because i you go to a dealer and and god
bless dealers but you go in for a
windshield wiper fixed and they come
back with 900 of things you've got to
have done it's total garbage so don't
that's where they make the most of their
money don't give them 2200 get a second
or a third opinion all right now now
when you do that um
you said you have a spouse
yes and also i already it's already in
the shop so they've already been working
on it and did most of the work already
was like yeah so you authorized this for
them to do all this work for 2500 you
signed off yes and then i regretted it
and that's what i'm calling i'm sorry
well i didn't know that well i would
have saved us 17 minutes okay
so you're on the hook for this call it a
stupid tax we got to move forward we got
to pay for this yeah i'm gonna get in
touch with them and say listen i can't
pay for this in full uh can i get on a
plan to pay this off as quickly as
possible and see what they say if
they're willing to work with you
um i hope they are
and on top of that we're not pulling
from retirement and we're not going to
credit card debt what we are going to do
okay is we might lose sleep doing side
jobs here and selling every single thing
that we own that is not tied down to the
house we're listing it on facebook
marketplace and craigslist we're we're
asking people around our community what
we can do to pick up some extra jobs and
we're gonna cash flow this thing which
means we're pausing the baby steps
temporarily to cover this emergency
okay so how quickly could you save up
two thousand dollars
well um
my hope is
well okay i shouldn't say hope but
um when i worked out the plan it we
should be able to pay it off um
by next month like at the latest right
um obviously we're going to try to work
really hard to pay it off this month
specifically um we do have that 400 an
emergency to put something toward it
um
but
that's yeah that's all we have right now
well get just be honest with them and
say listen i can put 10 down on this uh
payment for this car repair that's all i
have right now and this is a good faith
payment i'm making and the rest is going
to be here on this date and here's what
this looks like yeah and they may not
release the car until it's paid in full
and you're going to have to figure out
an arrangement to get around until then
but onward upward you're gonna get
through this cody you guys are on your
way proud of you thank you so much for
the call james is up in wichita falls
texas james how can we help
how are you guys doing uh we're having a
blast we got about two minutes or so so
we're gonna try to help you out what's
the question
so i am wanting to know whether or not i
should save up for my wedding
pay off my remaining debt
or just cash flow the rest of my school
whoa can we can we do all of this and
not go further into debt that's the
question and if that means pausing on
the debt snowball i'm okay with that
can you cash flow college and cash flow
the wedding
so the wedding is being paid for by her
family nice
so why are you saying you have to focus
on the wedding
well
it's more so my marriage rather than the
wedding
what's there to focus on
you're just trying to figure out whether
or not i should save up more because i
only have about four grand saved up i
don't know if that's gonna be enough to
cover us to cover what
just cover the marriage
marriage doesn't i don't even know what
that means there's no built-in cost to
being married is she gonna work
yes all right she's an emergency room
nurse all right well then she's fine
she's covering herself what i don't even
know what you mean by cover the marriage
there's nothing to cover here other than
you know they're gonna be some moving
expenses where are you guys going to
live
we're going to live in dallas in an
apartment
yes okay so we do need to make sure
we've got moving expenses covered uh
after the wedding which is probably
going to be the ballpark of a thousand
bucks maybe
about fifteen hundred okay so fifteen
hundreds for that so we're good there we
go
on cash flowing college how much further
do you have to get to graduate
i will be done in may and do you have
the money currently or have you already
paid
i do all right so once that's the final
bill is paid then we can go after
attacking this debt and if the wedding's
paid for then we're good so as soon as
you've got those two things buttoned up
let's start attacking this debt and
clean it as much as we can up before we
get married
okay
that's the game plan there it is james i
love that but that's the first time i've
heard that one before i didn't know
there was a built-in cost to marriage
how much do i need to cover them dowry
like you just give stacy upon the
wedding day here's five thousand dollars
oh man that's fantastic
yeah that's a tradition in many
countries still you gotta come with
cattle i don't know how that was gonna
have a cattle offering i did have a
camel at my wedding so maybe that was
the that was part of it yeah well that
was a great prop george campbell always
fun to be with you
thanks to kelly and the crew behind the
glass for all they do to make the show
so great thank you america for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you